before we move to statements i want to
say something about the selection of
amendments and new clauses for the
advanced
research and innovation agency bill
i told the house in my statement on the
29th of january 2020
but to speak of the house i'm committed
to transparency
and i respect and trust the advice from
clerks in this house
as the house will know and as this gun
may state
the chair is not expected to give
reasons for the decision on the
selection of amendments
however on exceptional basis i want to
say
something about why new clause 4 has not
been selected
i'm doing so on this occasion because
the high level of interest
in the new clause in the house and
outside it amendments and new clauses
which are not
within the scope of the bill are out of
order
asking may states the scope of the bill
represents reasonable limits
of its collective purposes as defined by
its existing
pauses and schedules in this instance
having taken advice from the house's
senior clerks
and the officer of speaker's council i
have deemed
that new clause 4 to be outside the
scope of the bill
new clause 4 is therefore not selected
and may not be debated today
i do wish to make a further point as we
all know
the government has through our standing
order significant control over the
business of the house
and considers on any given day
and its control is particularly strong
when it comes to the initiation
of public expenditure under the
international development official
development assistance target
act 2015 it is the duty of the secretary
of state
to ensure that the target for official
development assistance
to the amount of 0.7 of gross
national income is met by the united
kingdom each year
up until now however the house has
not and i repeat not had
an opportunity for a decisive vote on
maintaining the uk's commitment to the
statutory target
of 0.7 i expect that the government
should find a way to have this important
matter debated
and allowed the house to formally to
take
an effective decision
i should say that on an exceptional
basis
i will consider whether to hear any
staying on number 24 applications
by 5 30 today for debate to be held
tomorrow
application should reach my office by no
later than 5 o'clock this afternoon
having taken this exceptional step of
explaining my decision and selection
in this case i will only take one point
of order
and that is from the lead member for the
proposed amendment
andrew mitchell yeah thank you very much
mr speaker
further to your statement of course i
completely accept that you are the
referee on these matters
and that is that but mr speaker the
government front bench are treating
the house of commons with disrespect
they are avoiding a vote on the
commitments
that each of us made individually and
collectively
at the last general election on a
promise made
internationally and in the opinion of
some of britain's
leading lawyers the government is acting
unlawfully
mr speaker had we secured a vote on the
new clause tonight
i can assure the house it would have
secured the ascent of the house
by not less than a majority of nine and
probably of around
20 votes mr speaker in the week of the
british chairmanship of the g7
the government's failure to address this
issue will indisputably
mean that hundreds of thousands of
avoidable deaths
will result it is already attracting
criticism from
all around the other members of the g7
what advice
mr speaker do you have for my right
honourable and honorable friends and i
to seek to stop the government from
riding roughshod over parliament
in this way and seeking to thwart our
democratic rights
as members of the house of commons
can i first of all thank the right to
remember for giving
the cursive giving me advanced notes to
this point of order
on the first point the government may
have behaved unlawfully
i have to advise him that that will be a
matter for the court to determine not me
as he's well aware of and i i know that
he's
worked very hard at looking at that if
that was needed
on his more general point i've already
expressed my view that the house should
be given
opportunity to make an effective and i
repeat and effective decision
on this matter i've also indicated that
i will exceptionally be prepared to
accept
an application today for emergency
debate tomorrow
and i would say i share the house's
frustration
it is quite right that this house should
not continue to be taken for granted
but we must do it in the right way and i
believe the government needs respect
and need to come forward i totally agree
with the honorable member
not only for this house but the country
needs that this
is debated and earned and an effective
decision taken